Hi everyone.
Welcome to talks at Google today.
It is my pleasure to welcome a Jeremy's
Sonia and Anton Yelchin Burt Green Room.
Let's give a round of applause.
Great to be here.
Could you give us a brief
overview of what the film's about?
Sure.
It is a punk rock siege thriller is set
in the backstage green room of a concert
venue during a live concert and basically
an out of town band as a witness,
the aftermath of a backstage murder
and the club happens to be run by Nazi
skinheads and so they barricade
themselves in and tries to private night.
That's good summary. Uh,
so this is, I mean it's,
it's a very claustrophobic
siege, Phil. Um, you know,
it's very sort of limited
in the scope of where you,
was that always the intention
with it or did you ever,
were you tempted to go
outside the club with it?
Oh, I wanted to, I wanted to, but no,
I mean this scenario demanded that we
say in that pressure cooker scenario,
um,
my first film murder party
actually takes place in a enclosed,
actually it's a Brooklyn
warehouse and it's a, it's an,
it's an McCobb art party gone wrong.
And it's similar in tone
as far as like an overnight
sort of blood fests,
but that's more of a Gonzo horror comedy.
The, the key there is when
you're an independent filmmaker,
you're told do something in a single
location that'd be cheaper. Um,
it's just people talking in
a room. And for me, you know,
my attraction towards cinema is,
is visual.
And so I found that very,
uh, suppress. I was just,
I was just like, this is terrible.
All I do is listen to people talk.
It's not my thing. Um,
so my next film I do,
I've got out in the open road and explored
highways and forests and got a lot of
production value to that. And
then for green room, it just,
the scenario demanded that I promised
I'd never go back into that sort of
scenario, but I did. But this time I
had, I knew what I was getting into.
So I think we achieved a
certain level of craft. Yeah.
Um, you said that you said you're tracking
film is visual and this is one of your
first movie that you aren't the
cinematographer on. Correct.
What was it like sort of taking,
not necessarily step back is obviously
you're going to be very involved in the
visual aesthetic of it, but what
was that experience like? Yeah,
that was a big thing is that knowing
going into this is an ensemble performance
piece and there's pit bulls and shotguns
and gunfights and mayhem all throughout
the film that my attention
had to be elsewhere.
But if I was looking through the eye
piece of the camera and how I get this
tunnel vision,
that was blue ruin,
it was very quiet and almost
wordless for most of the film.
Green Room is just nonstop like
throttling and the emotional charge of the
characters had to be really
accounted for. And, and I,
I leaned heavily on Anton
and the whole cast for that.
Um,
but I definitely had to oversee many
departments and having a sim or target for
was actually a great
weight off my shoulders.
So Anton,
how did you get involved in the project?
Uh, in a pretty, pretty
standard way. I think I just, I,
I got the script and I read it
and I skyped with Jeremy and a,
I then ended up meeting
with him a little later,
actually a little bit later
actually. And then a, yeah, pretty,
pretty standard trajectory,
honestly. Uh, not,
nothing too exciting to relay here.
Okay.
I found the script in the street,
the street that I read through a mate,
that's all Jeremy was waiting on
the other side. What's it Michelle?
Michelle's going to say a
store man room to then drag it,
uh,
you up with you on that because experience
and like punk has been an influence
on your lives. Did that, did you know
that about Anton when you cast him or
us?
No,
I think that I have a
history and so to see,
and anytime I would love to tell
you about his band, Jeremy. Okay.
So my band name,
it was with my best buddies.
So like I love those guys.
So I've relayed to them over the years,
may times my dissatisfaction with
the name. But that being said,
I had this band and we had a great time
just being a really shitty punk band.
And we played a lot of gigs,
like the one in the,
in the film where, uh,
you played a six people.
Um,
uh,
and ironically I found out we're doing
our press day at the viper room tomorrow
in La and that's where we
would play Sundays at midnight.
So Sundays at midnight.
That's not like peak hour for a
show, you know. Uh, but we, we,
we had such a good time and I
think when I met Jeremy, um,
obviously it wasn't about like
I, yeah, I'd been in a bad mood.
It's about other things when you're
signing on for a film, I think.
But the feeling that you have
playing with your friends,
your best friends and sharing those times,
like if you're going on the road
to play or you're just playing,
just bonding over playing for six people.
And all of you feeling so low that
the six people having clap once,
um, is the best feeling in a way because
only you and your friends share that.
And that's kind of for me what was so
touching about this film is like pat and
his friends are all put in jeopardy,
but for pat he's seeing the fact that
his best friends are in jeopardy.
That to me was kind of the,
the heart and soul of the piece.
But like really what's touching that
you experience when you're playing with
your friends,
you know,
speaking of your friends,
there's also,
this is actually a character that we
meet that isn't a member of the band is,
is imaging boots character,
right? Cause this,
but you don't know who or what she is
and she emerges from the shadows and we
don't find out a lot about her even
through the course of the film. Um,
could you talk about her
sort of evolution is,
I feel like she's like
a hero at the end of it.
It was very important for me to have
a strong female character. And I like,
I like playing with the fact that she
starts as the girlfriend of the victim,
you know, and she's trapped in the
room with this band and then she,
we didn't even give her closeups
images of boots. Yeah. Whatever you're,
that you're in the background.
We cut off her frame, you know,
she'd be out of half out of frame,
kind of disregard her as a character,
but she kind of earns her way in to the
inner circle and it's really fun to see
that dynamic happened where, you
know, not to give any spoilers away,
but she does emerge as a central character
and she pretty much takes over and
kicks ass.
And you've worked with her before on
fight night, right? Uh, yeah. Sorry.
I was just like trying to negotiate all
this while Jeremy was so many layers.
Um, yeah, I was
happy to be able to work with him again.
I have so much respect for her
and so inspired by her. Um,
and the great thing is,
is,
is our work in fright night that has
literally nothing to do with this film.
I mean,
it was just like totally
different characters in a
totally different film and I
was just happy to be on set
with her again. It's always
nice to see your friends.
Uh, outer work murdered, murdered.
That's the kind of guy I say.
That's why I was casting this film.
My blood lust called hearted
willingness to throw. Your friends
are going to see a film
for you or somebody doesn't
get murdered or stabbed or
you know, if you dig deep,
there's, I kind of found
my, my way doing these genre
films, but um, I have a short film,
2004 called crabwalk.
It's a melancholy comedy.
Who would have thought? Um,
and yes, I will eventually
explore a lower body count,
but I think I'm actually getting
these in before I get too soft.
I'm a father of three very,
very fulfilling life at
home surrounded by love.
But these are the films that I loved
growing up and I'm trying to maintain that
connection long enough to, to, to,
to do them myself before it become
one of those guys that makes,
I don't know,
animated films for my kids.
He's standing around with them.
I know there's,
there's a lot of sort of violence and
viscera, but it didn't feel gratuitous,
which I mean that as a compliment.
Like it was like, yeah,
this is necessary because
this is the situation.
How did you negotiate that
kind of fine line between like,
oh is a slasher girls horror horror film?
And like this is horrifying.
It's,
it's to ratchet up intensity and all the
violence has a very articulate purpose
within the movie.
Um,
and sometimes it is like full frontal
Gore and it's a rub your face in it.
There's a transition in the film,
one of the key characters where she
becomes a killer and she is reluctant.
It's not like, again, there's no blood
loss to it. It's just like a very,
this is a war movie.
There's, there's two sides,
one very singular goal on one side and
then just pure survival on the other.
But for the kids and the punk rock
band to sort of acclimate to their new
environment and a step up and
to mount some kind of revolt,
they have to become killers. And
that's brutal. It's not just high five,
let's kill the bad guys.
It's, it's, it's holy smokes,
we're in far too deep and this
is not gonna end well. Um,
and sometimes you get a little gratuitous
close up if it's a non fatal wound,
but there is one in particular is
coming to mind that I am thinking of.
We could give a high five if you had no,
no, it's brutal. But the key is that,
that it's um,
it's coupled with an emotional component
and there is reverence for all the
characters. That's what sets it apart,
I hope is that either even like the,
the quote unquote bad guys, like when
there is a life lost, you feel it and it,
it's, it's, the intensity is real and the,
and the loss is real and
it's not supposed to wear.
There's a couple of high five moments
in the movie had pepper those in just so
it's satisfying narratively.
Um, speaking of the bad guys,
your villain is it never,
he did Patrick Stewart Moore. Feminine
and a good way. He was so scary.
Um,
so what was sort of having him as your
villain like onset just do the whole
process?
Well, you know, I think when,
whenever someone that is
accomplished as much as,
as Patrick has a, Patrick Stewart
has, when Sir Patrick Stewart Matrix,
when when you're on set with
someone like that, you're,
you're really fortunate because
the way that that man conducts
himself with everyone is incredibly,
I guess honorable is a good way to put it,
is so much respect for everyone.
And it goes without saying
it, you know, his career on,
on stage and screen it is immense
and he's incredibly accomplished.
But it's very important to see how human
beings that have achieved a lot behave
with everyone on set.
And that's my biggest takeaway is,
is seeing someone that is so
respectful, so lovely. Um,
and so kind with everyone.
And beyond that, uh,
I didn't talk to him very much because
he was trying to kill me. Um, but, uh,
uh, yeah, it's, it's really,
it's inspiring. You just
want to go out and be like,
all right,
well if I ever come anywhere close to
or even half as close to what he's done,
I just as a human being, these are lessons
that we have to learn along the way.
We make movies all together.
You know, it doesn't matter.
All of us are together in this sort of
shit show trying to make a film and we
all have to be respectful to one another
and that's like the most important
human part of making films I think.
I mean even as an antagonist,
I feel like he's actually in the
beginning at least he's a very sort of
respectful and it's all,
it feels sort of transactional and like
let's all be calm about this even though
the stakes are terrifying.
Yeah,
we're on record is pet.
This is Patrick Stewart's most quiet
performance on stage or a screen and his
entire career decibel wise or they can
literally Zach quiet and we miked him
clothes and the key there was like he
has such presence and authority that the
onetime he does sort of lose his cool
and yell at one of his underlings played
by Megan Blair in my, my good buddy.
Um, he does a face palm, you know,
it's really violent and impulsive and
he takes a breath and he apologizes and
then it carries on. And if we, other
than that he doesn't raise his voice.
I think it's all like this implied power
and like when he steps on a on scene,
he does not have to have monologues or,
or do anything that's like
trying too hard to be profound.
He's just this quiet authority
figure and it's creepy as hell.
Maybe. I noticed this part
of the film in particular,
just because this is Google and
we work at David, but I was like,
he found the one group
that there's a legitimate,
like I believe you when there's a reason
for them not being on social media and
people not knowing where they are.
Like yeah,
we don't post about who
we are and where we are.
And that kind of hurts
them in this scenario.
But was that just sort of an added
bonus, um, as apartment or, we did,
it was that sort of, part of it was
one of the things like, you know,
the Internet is cool, it's good, thanks.
You know,
how it affected music,
how it affected the
hardcore scene is terrible.
And it's because you no longer
have to show up to places.
You know, there's still vibrant
scenes in pockets throughout.
But like when I was in the
hardcore scene in the 1990s,
it was all about being there and
you couldn't click on anything.
You couldn't stream anything.
Um, it was very tactile and,
and that's what I was there for.
I was not like a guru with
a huge vinyl collection.
I can't drop a thousand names,
but I remember just being there,
it just sort of defined my youth.
Um,
and the ain't rights are this band trying
to hold on to that dream and that sort
of Pat's carry the character pad
men just said is to texture. Um,
so they refuse to go virtual,
um,
and talk about you have to show up,
you've got to be there.
And of course they pay the price,
but now the twist is because
greenery was coming out.
There's a lot of talk about hardcore
again and h one divorce put out this green
room radio, like all these gurus
talking about the old days.
That's kind of fun where the thesis
of my film might be proven wrong.
Maybe the Internet's awesome
because now we're talking about
these hardcore bands from the 809 is
that I grew up with and it's really fun.
[inaudible] going to Oregon.
You can play the viper room
again if we're going to play.
We played the viper room at midnight. You
guys can catch us there. And he saw this
sort of speaking of the Internet,
its effect on your career. You,
you are someone who definitely sort of
hits you've built your career on your own,
was very, you know, I, I think when you
funded murder party on your own and,
and it's just sort of blue
ruin and blew own buddy,
what do you think of sort of
this phenomenon of like how,
how do you think it would
have been different if you
were, um, sort of becoming,
coming into your own as a filmmaker
now when it says the age of Youtube and
people are being discovered online or
people are sell funding crowdfunding?
I used that for blue ruin too.
I use everything.
Yeah, whatever I could
get. But I think, um,
I felt alone without access.
I tried to make movies mostly of my
high school friends and murder party,
got distribution,
which is a huge coup for an unknown film
with unknown filmmakers behind it. Um,
and then for blue ruin, you know,
I started to acclimate, you know,
digital cameras were getting way better.
I was using these small DSLR
type cameras to make that movie.
Um,
and it wasn't until promoting that Phil,
I mean we got you submitted
a old fashioned DVD copy
to directors' fortnight and
can, and, and that was where everything
shifted. We got into that festival,
played on the world stage, like the most
prestigious festival in the world. Um,
but when we marketed blue ruin,
I saw the power of social media.
I it caught fire on Twitter.
They broke, you know,
the top 10 on iTunes and overall and just,
uh,
I'm still on Twitter because
of that. So maybe, maybe I'll,
I'll retreat later,
but I'm loving it.
And just being part of
this tour right now,
like just seeing my film reflected
in the eyes of audience members,
it's like what I,
what I love.
And you remember why you make films
because you get so close to it over the
course of the two years making it,
you kind of can't see it for what it is.
And then when people,
you just ask them for 94 minutes to
come and survive this insane punk rock
thriller.
And then they do and you high five and
then you remember why you make them in
the first place.
Which of the characters do you think
each of you or it's not as like in this
film, I'm like Reese
obviously. Um, so aggro
could you take it down and really try?
I might just flip this table over here.
I'm a split between it actually.
Reece and pat pretty much was
actually a real tiger is a real Sam.
It was a real tad based on people.
But,
but I think I definitely
pad is the expendable basis.
That's how I felt in the
hardcore scene. Ouch. No,
this has been hammered home
quite a bit over the course.
Well,
in a while ago I was about
15 pounds heavier with,
with muscle and worked out and
I was actually amongst my crew,
the Reese type character. I'm
not anymore, but I felt like pat.
Um, but yeah, it is.
A lot of this is based on my experiences
and mostly that of my friends. Like I,
we had hardcore bands in Virginia.
We'd go to DC for shows,
but my buddies were the
talented musicians. I just
yelled into the microphone.
Um,
and some of their songs actually his,
the fictional band and greener in place,
the songs that I heard in high school
written by my buddies. So it's,
it's really coming full circle.
And this is a way,
this whole film was an
archive of my youth,
like making crazy genre films and being
in punk rock bands and hardcore shows
and just like,
it's a way to archive that cause
I'm looks so soft and lame.
I want to just a little bit of street
cred and green room I hope gives me a
little bit.
Okay. Absolutely. Um, what's, what's,
I think my last question is
what's something you hope
people take away from this
film?
The elation of surviving a purely
like physical experience that that's,
you know, it's, it's fiction and
it's two dimensional on a screen,
but I want the experience to be real
and so far so good. It's really,
um, there's, if you watched
it a second or third time,
there's all kinds of layers of political
commentary and he can go on about the
intellectual nature of this movie.
But I want that visceral experience.
And I think it's what's lacking in cinema.
Even when we get to big spectacle
and we can explode worlds,
and I don't really feel much.
And Green Room is this hyperintense
intimate action movie that is grounded not
only by authenticity and it has its
fair share of violence and mayhem,
but it's the actors.
It's the performances that makes it
drives home the reality and that that
terrifying intensity that you feel like
you are with the band and the rug has
been pulled out from under you and you
have no idea where it's going to go.
I mean, I, I feel like that's the
director's statement right there.
So I don't really know what
I can add to that. Well,
what do you want them to take away?
Just how sick I am playing bass. Yeah,
there you go. But don't forget that
you're expendable. Okay. Thanks Ben.
Thank you both so much for joining
us today. Cause the green room,
you.